how do you curse so much for a guy who  doesn't need to because i only believe  in authenticity it's how i talk  like when i think about do i care about  my employees it feels more  like in my brain and my heart and my  soul do i give a [ __ ] about my employees  more than do i care about my employees  that's how my  that's from my brain and heart to my  mouth i am willing to deal with the  ramifications  of me being my full self do you curse at  home a ton  in front of your kids yep i'm just not  devastated to go into my fourth grade  like teacher and and mrs thompson's like  you have a real problem i'm like what's  that mrs thompson  your daughter curses i just don't see  that as a real problem  me and mrs thompson just don't see the  world the same way again  i'm the byproduct of mrs thompson  telling me my whole life that i would be  a failure  mrs thompson thought that a d in science  was going to be  my downfall just like she thinks saying  [ __ ] is her downfall  i don't agree